I mean you've never had like real
vitriol or you know particularly nasty
trash talk like you've always been you
know pretty uh like honorable and and uh
positive about your promotion yeah
exactly that's uh that's just who I am
right like and there's something I'm
proud of as well no I know what is the
entertainment business but the beauty of
it is uh we can entertain with these you
know what I mean in the Octagon uh you
know so it's
I get it I get like another but I mean
that everyone thinks that's the only way
to promote yourself but I mean there's
still many ways in many ways I'm I'm
happy with where I've got myself uh and
to be myself through that whole process
for sure so I'm very happy that I'm very
proud of that I saw your countrymen I
remember Whitaker talking about how he
feels his lack of salacious track Trash
Talk has prevented him from getting big
fights and uh I I wonder because it's
not always necessary yeah well like uh
you're right
you know it's it it definitely uh Canada
you've seen all the time you see guys
get a couple of Knockouts obviously you
need the Knockouts but that trash talk
as well it can sure it can the hype can
go up real quick yeah Fast Track you to
things and and that's uh that's that's
legit you know and like that's uh no lie
we see it happen all the time and yeah
you get a lot of good opportunities from
it you know what I mean and uh the
money's gonna be good and all that's
going to Fast Track you but but at the
same time some people are just that's
who they are anyway so it works well and
then you get guys that are going to be
just put on a shower and all that and
you can you can see some of them and
again like his name's always going to
come up I've said some things but I mean
I don't want to have a bad blood with
the guy but you see like someone like
Colby Covington who he knows he he knows
he plays that sort of role I'm gonna
play it you know what I mean which is
you know it's it's weed it's a weed sort
of thing to do so for me I just couldn't
do that she was on his way out of the
UFC because his fights were deemed so
boring with all the wrestling uh I read
the style of wrestling I should say and
his Trash Talk saved his career so power
Zoom so there you go so that and then
you you look so as much as people want
to hate it and here I am saying that
like I couldn't do it
but you'd be lying to yourself if you
didn't think that benefited him it put
him in a much better position so like I
can say what I want people can say
whatever they want at the end of the day
he's way waking up probably a lot more
money than he would have if he didn't do
it big time and at the end of the day
even if he isn't that type of guy the
people who he cares about or care about
him know exactly who he is if everyone
else thinks he's a piece of [__] or
whatever who cares my family know what
I'm all about so right you can't hate on
that so and that's why I've always
sometimes I get it it's just not me
that's that's what I'm trying to say not
only do I not hate on it I mean
I've been very candid to say that I am
so invested that I enjoy disliking Colby
Covington so much that I'm more excited
for his fights than anybody yeah and I
just can't stand the guy
you know but um
yeah go ahead yeah well that's like a
marketing sort of a tool like you hear
it a lot of the time where people want
to people will pay to watch to watch him
lose yeah so like you know I mean that
bad blood that happens like oh no is
this guy gonna you know get get him and
like we've had guys uh even May weather
you know you're Mayweather still you
know people are still waiting to see him
before you know what I mean but uh it's
probably not gonna happen with someone
like Mayweather but like a lot of people
uh made a a career off that and like
even in Australia we've had guys that
literally some they actually I've been
told very nice guys uh Anthony mundine
but he would play the villain and you'd
make probably one of the most uh amounts
of money in Australian boxing because
that's the you know people that have
watched that and so again you gotta you
gotta understand that it's entertainment
it is yeah do you like shopping on
Amazon I do and good news is Stevo's
butt wipes for your butthole are
available on Amazon and if you want a
real bundle of a deal you can get
Stevo's hot sauce for your butthole plus
Stephen's butthole destroyer and
steambo's butt wipes for your butthole
it's the butthole bundle available on
Amazon right now
yeah dude